plus que des meeting aux allures de
grand concert plus que des pas de danse
pour haranguer la foule
donald trump à changer la politique
américaine par un style unique
il y a quatre ans les états unis et le
monde découvrait le tropisme et selon
plusieurs experts outre atlantique ce
courant n'est pas près de disparaître
le tropisme qu'il perdure par le biais
de sa famille ou avec d'autres
catégories de politiciens qui s'en
rapprocherait parlerais et à gérer de
façon très similaire à celle de donald
trump restera encore sans doute présent
pour un bon moment
[Applaudissements]
donald trump ou semble avoir laissé une
trace indélébile
sa popularité ne cesse de grandir en
témoignent les chiffres pour cette
élection présidentielle le candidat
républicain a d'ores et déjà recueilli
70 millions de voix soit 7 millions de
plus qu'en 2016
sans compter les réseaux sociaux et ses
88 millions d'abonnés sur twitter
le milliardaire new yorkais fascine et
ne se voit surtout pas échoué face à joe
biden le fait d'être en concurrence avec
le pire candidat de l'histoire de la
politique présidentielle met la pression
sur moi
imaginez que je perde que vais-je faire
je ne vais pas me sentir très bien je
devrais peut-être quitter pays je ne
sais pas maîtrise de la communication et
poids des mots make america gloasguen
rendre sa grandeur à l'amérique
donald trump nationalistes plus que
jamais à l'échelle locale et
internationale le président américain a
conquis plusieurs électorat et soutien
précieux dans la conquête du pouvoir
celui de républicains évangélique des
catholiques conservateurs comme la juge
amy coni barrette récemment nommé à la
cour suprême
donald trump a d'ailleurs nommé trois
juges au cours de son mandat l'actuel
président laisse derrière lui des
héritiers politiques comme son fils de
donald trump junior déjà actif durant la
compagne de 2016 est davantage présent
médiatiquement en 2020 un possible
successeur capable comme son père de
manier l'art de la provocation
l'absence total d'actions de la part de
presque tous les espoirs du parti
républicain en 2024 est assez étonnante
il dispose d'une plateforme parfaite
pour montrer qu'ils sont prêts et
capables de se battre mais ils vont
plutôt se rétracter devant la foule des
médias ne vous inquiétez pas le vrai
donald trump eux va se battre et ils
peuvent être de simples spectateurs
comme d'habitude objectif 2024 donc pour
la guinée ce titre ' père au fils les
rumeurs ont déjà circulé du côté de la
maison blanche
trump et des conseillers ont eu des
discussions au sujet d'une possible
candidature en 2024
s'il devait perdre sa réélection face à
joe biden on ne sait pas s'il va passer
à l'action
mais la possibilité a été évoquée en
2024 donald trump fêtera ses soixante
dix huit ans l'âge prochain de joe biden
le tropisme un courant une idéologie
républicaine qui n'est pas prête de
s'envoler